-A new documentary
about Pope Francis
was released last week
and in it,
the Pope says,
for the first time ever,
that he thinks same-sex couple
should be able to have
civil unions.
One of our writers,
Jenny Hagel, is gay
and she's here to comment.
Hi, Jenny!
-Hi, Seth.
I'm here at the Vatican
and everyone is buzzing.
The Pope has said
that same-sex couples
should be allowed
to have civil unions.
This is really exciting stuff!
-Is it? I mean, I haven't
heard people advocate
for civil unions
since the late '90s.
I mean, it feels a little,
I don't know, outdated.
-Seth, the Catholic Church
is an old institution.
Sometimes, change comes slowly
but when it comes,
it is thrilling.
Oh.
Wow, Seth!
There's some more breaking news.
This is huge!
The Pope has just said he thinks
we should all get
dial-up Internet.
-Oh, wow, Jenny, are you sur
you're not getting
an old news update?
-No, Seth, this happened today
The Pope has given his blessing.
He said we can all get
dial-up Internet,
and I think that is
huge progress.
-I don't think it is.
Again, it sounds
kind of outdated.
-Oh! Oh.
Seth, the Pope has just
released a statement.
It says, "Have you guys hear
'The Miseducation
of Lauryn Hill'?
It's a great album.
You should check it out."
Wow, Seth, wow!
This Pope is very cool!
-Is he?
-Oh, oh, wait, there's more.
He also said he's got some
great Monica Lewinsky jokes.
He's going to read them
from the balcony
in St. Peter's Square
and he feels confident
they will age really well.
-No, they're not going
to age well.
-Seth, this is major!
-Jenny, I don't think thes
little bits of news
warrant all this excitement.
-Of course they do.
Francis became Pope in 201
and it took him
just seven short years
to get onboard with a policy
that everyone else
abandoned 20 years ago.
A lot of straight people calle
to tell me this news
and I was very excited.
As excited as if they had told
me they just got a car phone
-Oh, I see what you're doing
You're saying there's a reason
people abandoned civil unions --
because they're not equal
to marriage.
Telling same-sex couples
they should have civil union
sounds a lot like saying
they're second-class citizens.
-That's exactly what I'm saying.
Oh, my God.
-Don't tell me.
-Seth, you're not going
to believe this.
-Oh, I really don't want
to know.
-Seth, the Pope
just got a new haircut
and it. is. fresh!
-What?!
Is that the Pope
with the Rachel?
-Yes!
He's on the cutting edge!
-Oh, my goodness!
This is amazing!
Jenny Hagel, everyone.